dass wir das noch erleben dürfen meine
damen und herren die cdu hat einen
kanzlerkandidaten armin laschet ist es
geworden
nach einer tagelangen zangengeburt ohne
betäubung
damit ist armin laschet offiziell der
erste lebende mensch der einen söder
bezwungen hatten wurde ein viertel
seines eigenen partei vorstand wollten
ihn ausdrücklich nicht genau wie weite
teile der cdu-fraktion viele
landesverbände aber dass in fußnoten
ab jetzt wird nach vorne geguckt in der
partei ja mit armin laschet als
frontmann spielt die cdu nur noch auf
sieg und zwar mit einer ganz klaren
strategie ja ich bin ministerpräsident
von nordrhein-westfalen trete jetzt an
und wie wir uns für den fall den wir
alle versuchen zu verhindern dass wir
nämlich die wahl gewinnen
dazu werden wir uns zu gegebener zeit
ein lassen ja gute idee was ich mich nur
frage was war denn jetzt bitte der sinn
von dem ganzen cdu/csu gemetzeln von
diesem tage lang kanzler krieg am ende
sind doch beide beschädigt wobei
großartige unterhaltung war es natürlich
schon
das muss man neidlos zugeben er gibt es
jetzt übrigens als zehnteilige serie bei
zdfinfo der kanzler krieg von 2021
wirklich mit allen highlights hier zum
beispiel die legendäre szene wo sie
damit der bayerischen luftwaffe nachts
berlin angreift ganz toll oder hier die
vola sieht sich mit seinen allerletzten
geträumt im adenauer haus verschanzt und
dann im letzten moment gerettet zu
werden von volker bouffier mit der
hessischen kamera
das ist geschichte zum anfassen
emotionaler höhepunkt des kasseler
kriegs war natürlich so dass
kapitulation reden wo er beim dank an
seine unterstützer in der
schwesterpartei cdu nochmals vormacht
wie so vieles laschet mobbing genau geht
ich bedanke mich sehr bei
arbeitsgemeinschaften gerade bei den
jungen bei den modernen bei denen die
auf zukunft aus waren für ihre wirklich
überragende unterstützung perfekt
gemacht verstehe seine fans jung modern
zukunft die vom laschet pflegestufe 3
die riechen streng es ist total
undemokratisch den söder nicht zu nehmen
obwohl die menschen ihm wollen und
lieben könnte es jetzt aus dem lager
tatsächlich sind umfragen aber gar keine
wahlen fragen sie mal ihren spaß
er dachte neulich auch noch er wird
kanzler heute ist ja schon froh wenn
ihnen einer grüßt oder in den worten
eines blutjungen hoffnungsträgers also
umfragen sind wie liebe es schwierig
würde immer nur die hälfte glauben
bestimmt nicht alles was gesagt wird
eben
tatsache ist natürlich da steckt aktuell
nicht mehr viel union in der union
mindestens zwei cdu-ministerpräsidenten
und peter altmaier sind in der nacht der
entscheidung zum söder übergelaufen von
technischen problemen mal ganz zu
schweigen
auch die cdu scheitert hier an der
digitalisierung es sollte geheim
abgestimmt werden aber mails aus dem
adenauer-haus haben ihre empfänger wohl
nicht erreicht tatsächlich waren sie
wohl im spam-ordner angekommen was das
klingt ja fast nach einem hacker-angriff
wer könnte da denn dahinter stecken wenn
er am ende müssen wir sagen hat der
zocker söder den laschen wohl schlicht
unterschätzt denn man kann ja über armin
sagen was man will aber nehmerqualitäten
hat da man aber hallo
in der unions fraktion musste er sich
von parteikollegen sätze anhören wie an
der basis ist man verzweifelt dass man
mit so einem in den wahlkampf ziehen
muss wenn er jede andere wäre heulend
rausgerannt aber nicht der armin kann
man das lernen
wie man will dass du kannst deine frage
sind bei schülern geben endlich auf die
cdu-fraktion hast dich alle cdu
landesverbände hoffentlich alle 10 uhr
kreis am ende hoffentlich und weißt du
was die cdu frauen wollen die altern
ich würde ich nicht mehr gehen wenn die
letzte kandidat wäre es jetzt auf dvd
einstecken können wie armin laschet 90
minuten beleidigungs meditationen das
war mal ganz hilfreich das zuhören
ja sie ist resilienz könig laschet muss
man auch können und echt mal bei allem
respekt cdu und csu hatten zweieinhalb
jahre zeit einen nachfolger für angela
merkel zu finden
und das sind dann die beiden besten die
ihnen einfallen was sagt denn die basis
sind keinen von beiden gut halt eben der
der eine versucht halt eben den dicken
mann raus zu lassen und der andere ist
irgendwie ein clown der dicke und der
clown
das klingt wie eine comedy-serie bei sat
1 nicht zu beneiden sind jedenfalls die
zuständigen marketing lerche im
konrad-adenauer-haus man ernsthaft wie
willst du als cdu die marke laschet im
kommenden wahlkampf nach all dem noch
als premium kanzler material verkaufen
wie geht das fragen wir sebastian
pufpaff seinen job er muss das cdu
kampagnen team motivieren herr puffer
auf erst mal herzlich ist beileid
ja das können sie sich sparen ich sage
ihnen wir werden das ding rom
aber so sonja sie hier keiner wollte den
armin aber jetzt jetzt ist er unser mann
ich gehe sogar soweit und sage die jungs
und ich wir sind heiß auf armin oder
oder ist auch egal ich habe direkt auf
den slogan ist mir gerade eingefallen
und zwar lieber am knie als armer
chakalaka wider willen ja gut die
plakate haben wir jetzt schon fertig
könne jetzt nicht alles wegschmeißen
wer kann den abenteuerlichen der lasche
durchsetzt das ist so als ob der sv
meppen real madrid schlagen würde
egal wir arbeiten jetzt mit dem was wir
haben und wen haben wir nicht markus
söder auch klaus jetzt würden
armin laschet armin laschet ist
kommunikativ teamfähig kompromissbereit
oder wie man in der pr branche sagt
stingl langweilig ja stimmt aber
aber ich bin armin laschet und darauf
können sie sich verlassen
immerhin und sagt nächstes plakatmotiv
ich werde auch morgen noch armin laschet
heißen das verspricht ihnen armin
laschet donner oder von leute wirklich
mein team immer spaß letztlich ist ja
auch völlig wurscht wer antritt weder
laschet noch söder stehen für
irgendwelche inhalte
die cdu hat ja nicht mal ein
wahlprogramm wir bieten schon jetzt die
bürger uns ideen zu schicken weil wir
selber keine mehr haben hier und das ist
kein fake
die aktion heißt ernsthaft mach mit beim
machen
das klingt wie ein trainingsprogramm für
kinder die aufs treppchen sollen oder
elvis vom prosser gut verteidigt jetzt
klingt aber selber irgendwie demotiviert
finde ich ja natürlich wie werden sie
denn drauf wenn sie armin laschet
formaten müssten ja weil sie um sackers
breite den söder verpasst haben
verstehen sie was wir jetzt haben
distanzieren ich gucke gerne fernsehen
gerne tatort und lese gerne und was wir
hätten haben können das ist das hier
[Musik]
und dieser weg ein egomane ohne
prinzipien das ist ein marketing traum
entschuldung
so kommen wir nicht weiter männer ab
jetzt geht hier die wilde lasche post ab
denn wer ist unser mann armin soll das
leck mich am arsch
hallo leute ich bin's der heute-show
[Musik]
hersteller
wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß und liebt -
wollt dann abonniert jetzt den kanal
was zur hölle ist minimal hersteller
[Musik]